in the last couple of videos we set up a
scenario where company a intends to
acquire company b and they're going to
do it by issuing 2 million shares and
then giving those 2 million shares to
the shareholders of company b and
company b shareholders will give
essentially all of their ownership away
so there will be an exchange two million
of company a shares for one million of
company b shares or on a per share basis
the owners of company b will give up one
of their shares
and in exchange they will get two shares
of company a
they will get two shares in company and
we saw that if everyone thought that
this transaction was going to happen
theoretically whatever a is trading at b
should trade at twice that because
people know that they'll always be able
to trade in or when the transaction
happens they'll be able to trade in a b
for two of these a shares now what
happens in a situation or why would a
situation happen
where b doesn't trade at twice of a so
this is the theoretical trading twice as
a so this is 2 times
2 times a what happens if it doesn't
trade there what happens if b's shares
are trading i'm just in a color i
haven't used for what if it's trading a
little bit
what if it's trading a little bit lower
there well that might be the case
because some people don't think that the
transaction is going to happen so
they're not willing to pay they're not
willing to pay that full premium 4b but
let's say that this were to happen and
you are working at some type of a hedge
fund that has some type of model maybe
it's a mathematical model maybe you have
some type of shady information where you
know for a fact you are a hundred
percent certain that this transaction is
going to close and it's definitely going
to close it's definitely going to close
for with these terms 2 million shares of
a in exchange for 1 million shares of b
now your temptation might be well why
don't i just buy shares of why don't i
just buy these shares of b because they
will go up but what if the whole market
goes down what is the stock of a
what if the stock of a goes down like
this then 2 times a will also go down so
you don't want to just buy the stock of
b thinking it's going to go up because
if the transaction is really going to
happen b is just going to track two
times the price of a
so the best way to do it is to really
set up a bit of a pair trade here and so
what you would do is if you think the
transaction is definitely happening you
could buy
you could buy one share let me write
this down
you could buy
you could buy one share of b
share of b so you've gone long one share
of b and then you can short
you can short two shares
two shares
of a and the reason why this will work
and this will only work if you know the
transaction is going to happen is
because right now
two shares of a are going to be
at any point since since b is trading a
little bit of a discount to that the two
shares of a are going to be worth more
than the one share of b so when you
short two shares of a maybe maybe we're
at this point right here well let's
let's say we're at we're at this point
right on that day that everything was
announced so when you short two shares
of a you're going to get sixty dollars
you're going to get
sixty dollars just as a review shorting
is you set you borrow the stock you sell
it you're gonna have to buy it back at
some future date so you owe someone two
shares of a and when you buy one share
of b where it's not going to be trading
at 60 it's going to be trading at some
discount so let's say that that costs
you
so that costs
55 dollars so it's trading a little bit
of discount to 2 times a
so clearly just here you have netted so
60 minus 55 you have netted five dollars
five dollars net and then assuming the
transaction happens at some future date
when the transaction closes that one
share of b that you had you can exchange
it for two shares of a
so you get two times a and then you
could use that to cover your short
position so you use that to cover your
short position
and you you're left standing with five
dollars that you essentially made well
there is the risk that the transaction
didn't close but assuming the
transaction happened this was kind of a
kind of a free five dollars for for your
taking